India Supreme Court has upheld the 2019
decision by the government to revoke the
special status of the Indian
administered Jammu and Kashmir it's
ordered the government to hold new
elections in the region by the end of
September next year the decision
followed a series of legal challenges
judges rulle that jamu and Kashmir
status as a semi-autonomous region was
temporary and removing it was
constitutional we're joining us now from
new delhi's journalist and author Saba
Naki good to see you miss Naki what if
anything does the Court's decision mean
for the future of the region because the
government has been carrying on with its
plan changes since it revoked kashmir's
autonomy it it closes a chapter in uh
Indian in subcontinental history because
Kashmir was an issue all for all the
years of since we were in independent
nation uh but it closes a chapter which
and it will be popular across India
except in the valley of Kashmir this
decision this action by the government
which took away the special status of
Kashmir Kashmir has not had an elected
government since then uh it will be it
is very difficult for India to go back
now into that time when Kashmir was
described as a disputed territory of
sort of we've just been pushed forward
and do you accept people do you think
that the people of the Kashmir Valley
the Muslim majority Kashmir Valley do
you expect any resistance to this
closing of the chapter as you describe
it from
them you know uh just to put things in
perspective Kashmir was festering since
the found it's a foundational problem of
the subcontinent since India and
Pakistan were for formed on on
particular ideas of nationhood it was a
legacy of the British just as Israel was
carved out 47 we had the partition and
Independence of India and we had that
problem left by Colonial Masters so it
was always it was always considered a
disputed territory uh by the by Pakistan
now in India we we're not going to have
a discussion about that anymore the
thing is that India is is a powerful
country right now and the government of
prime minister Narendra Modi for all its
majoritarianism remains a popular
government the decision and on that PO
you know on that popularity the decision
comes ahead of the general election next
year revoking kashmir's autonomy was
very important to prime minister mod and
his Hindu nationalist BJP do you see
them trying to use this court decision
to their advantage in the
election absolutely it's going to be one
of the talking points and the thing is
the other parties the so-called
opposition parties which are National
and Regional in India they they can't
oppose him on that that's outside of
Kashmir which is which was the only
Muslim majority state in India uh in
other places it's almost impossible to
say very much about uh the very troubled
history of Kashmir the problem the
problem with going back to the original
status was that even that created
problems we had constant acts of
terrorism we had constant resistance we
had it was the most militarized place in
the world we had all of that now we have
uh we had a decision taken by the
government which was absolutely
but there's no elected government over
there so the Court verdict has also put
a date that by September we have to have
an elected government and so let's see
but there is going to be resistance but
let me just put it to you very bluntly
the way things are people would just
have to take it you know they just have
to take it and I'm seeing voices of
people who were earlier part of the
resistance of the idea of Kashmir
Independence many of them are already
compromising that is very I'm noticing
that yeah understand that is journalist
and author sa joining us live from New
Delhi thank you very
much thank you